welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber Thursday marks day eight
in the trial of Doomsday cult Mom Lori
valo dabel and the husband of valo's
former best friend took the witness
stand for the prosecution long crime
correspondent Gigi McKelvey has the
Scoop from the Boise Idaho courtroom
I'm Gigi McKelvey outside the Ada County
Courthouse where we have had Witnesses
on and off the stand all morning it's
been pretty quick for direct and
cross-exam the most notable witness we
had today was David Warwick who is the
husband of Melody Gibb who testified
earlier in this case where he recounted
the weekend he spent in Rexburg which
was the last weekend JJ Vela was alive
the last time he saw JJ Alex Cox was
holding him JJ was asleep with his head
on Alex's shoulder and that finished up
the morning's testimony we are
anticipating some testimony about cell
phone pings which should be interesting
to see where people were at crucial
times during this case stay with long
crime Network for the latest I'm Gigi
McKelvey
well another close connection to the
defendant testified on Wednesday while
living in Hawaii with her husband Chad
Lori valo dabell befriended a woman
named April Raymond all three actually
attended the same Latter-Day Saints
church together and on the stand Raymond
recalled conversations where valo dabel
talked about her separation from
ex-husband Charles vallo who is now
deceased the Doomsday cult mom also
shared a recommendation that Raymond
should leave her family behind
when she said Charles was no longer
Charles how was that connected to her
talking about separating from Charles
sure
um
so she had said that Charles was already
dead and that there was a demon living
inside him and kind of using his body as
a host
and that the Demon's name was Ned Snyder
did you follow up on that
um did she give you any sort of evidence
of this when I asked how do you know
that it's not Charles she said because
he's shorter
now during these various conversations
did the defendant ever talk to you about
participating in the formation of the
hundred and forty four thousand who are
supposed to Shepherd in the second
coming of Christ
yes that was a conversation the first
night that she stayed with me when it
was just she and Tyler okay
um and what did Lori valo say to you
about that she said that she had been
appointed a leader of one of the 144 000
and that she was there to gather me and
um what did you understand gather you
meant
to join
join her okay
and what did she say was going to be
needed for you to do in order to join
her in this group that I would need to
be separated from my children okay
um did she indicate
um why
basically that my children were raised
I'd fulfilled my role in their lives and
that I had a greater calling a greater
mission to perform with her okay
did she indicate that
um what you should do with your kids
basically just leave them with their
father okay
all right I'm here with my co-host legal
analyst Brian buckmeyer Terry Austin to
break all this down Brian will start
with you so the text message was read
aloud in court today I want to talk to
you about this it was Chad dabell
sending this to his first wife Tammy day
Bell a day before Tyler Ryan went
missing and the message says quote I
spotted a big raccoon along the fence I
hurried and got my gun and he was and he
was still walking along I got close
enough that one shot did the trick he is
now in our pet cemetery fun times we
know that Ryan's body was found buried
in daybell's Pet Cemetery six months
later it seems like maybe this is a way
he was trying to cover the tracks of the
burial of the body but my question to
you is how badly does this text hurt
Lori not Chad Lori very badly Jesse and
this is why at first glance it's a
conversation or a text sorry between
Chad and Lori how does this have
anything to do oh sorry Chad and Tammy
how does this have anything to do with
Lori but conspiracy is how it has to do
with Lord because so long as there's an
agreement between two or three three
people or more if one of those
participants in that agreement takes
steps in furtherance of that conspiracy
all people who agreed to the conspiracy
are guilty so this could easily be a way
of Chad covering up the tracks of
killing Tyler and JJ and kind of pushing
people off the scent there if Lori was a
part of the agreement and you believe
that that's part of the conspirac
charges yep that's 100 right now Terry I
want to talk about something else what
were the key takeaways for you from
April Raymond's testimony well one of
the first things Jesse is that she
cooperated the testimony of Melanie Gibb
and she also corroborated the testimony
of zulima if you think about it they
were all followers they all believed
what she was saying and ultimately they
all stopped believing from a substance
standpoint they all three said that Chad
was or rather that um that Charles was
you know a demon inside of him a demon
by the name of Ned Schneider that he
behaved strangely that he was shorter
and so they all said that he was
possessed and ultimately this is the
reason why he had to be you know killed
at the end of the day Terry don't feel
bad there's just so much overlap here
and so much consistency in these stories
they all sound very similar but how many
people thought they were demons
according to this logic we are moving
away from the Doomsday cult mom trial to
cover another Whirlwind case this one
out of Atlanta and the craziest part is
an attorney has been arrested before
trial has even begun rapper Young Thug
is being tried alongside several
co-defendants from the alleged gang
known as young slime life or YSL they're
all facing charges connected to alleged
Rico operations that includes the death
deaths of two rival gang members jury
selection has been underway since
January but no progress has been made
due to endless disruptions in the
courtroom including the smuggling of
Contraband and juror misconduct and this
week the disruptions have somehow made
their way to defense counsel that's
right Anastasia the defense attorney for
Miles Farley was arrested on Thursday
after a routine check of his bag
officers discovered a bottle of
prescription medication and arrested
menetis immediately afterwards in fact
as officers closed in on him he
allegedly tossed his phone to another
attorney but it instead hit one of the
officers so the attorney has been
charged with simple battery on a law
enforcement officer possession of pills
not in their original container and
disrupting Court proceedings but this
isn't minetis's first rodeo he is being
held in contempt by the judge a few
months back while the reasoning is
unclear He was ordered to pay a fine of
250 dollars and also by his colleagues
lunch you heard that right that order
was actually addressed during court this
week check it out
you were held in contempt young man
visit that again we can certainly open
it up but I satisfied your contempt by
you paying 250 which you did and I have
and I have a receipt from that of your
choosing which that was done to uh
Miles College I had that receipt here
and the other thing was to purchase
lunch for each of your attorney
colleagues in this case on Friday March
the 17th from Jason's Deli so prong
one's been settled
prong two was uh was uh you were
supposed to buy that by your colleagues
lunch by that date Mr manette is your uh
this was in satisfaction of me not
sending you to jail for 20 days so if if
if that's the case well then I will
revisit the basis for your contempt but
I thought that in fact I'll have Miss um
Weaver go ahead and pull that order pull
the part of the record but I did in fact
I I did not hold you in I did not go
ahead and sentence you to the 20 days I
said that this would status once you
apologized I said
you can pay because remember you were
going to do a uh I was going to have you
do a report as well or a uh
um
um a written product I was also gonna
but instead instead of doing that
we settled on the 250 and we settled on
your buying ones for your colleagues on
the 17th of March
so that was my understanding
and that was satisfy then that will
satisfy this course this this Court's
concern okay
so Brian this judge makes the attorney
pay a fine buy lunch orders another
attorney in contempt to write a lengthy
essay on courtroom decorum is any of
this standard operating procedures is
this Fair it's not standard in any way
shape or form however it is well within
the power of the judge to
create different sentencing requirements
of an attorney in contempt arguments or
proceedings like this I mean I'm not
surprised when I look at the I'm
guessing the age of the defense attorney
this seems utterly childish this seems
like a power play on the judge saying I
have power over you go write an essay
little boy go buy your your superiors
lunch little boy it's what you do to
Junior attorneys in big firms I think
it's ridiculous and unfair but I think a
lot of things ridiculous unfair in
courtrooms well Terry now that menennis
has been arrested what happens to the
case against his client miles Farley
well first of all he's going to have to
get a new attorney now that his case is
you know going to be separate and that
is what the judge said is he wanted this
case severed and I think it's going to
work to the advantage of Farley to have
the case severed the case now is from 28
down to 13 defendants Folly will now be
able to make his own case if he wants to
he can point fingers at the other
defendant so I think at the end of the
day it's going to work to his Advantage
but I do think that the judge is taking
it out far too harshly on these
attorneys and I think arresting him for
having you know drugs that he had a
prescription for and throwing a phone
that accidentally hit someone that is
probably a bit too far it's got a little
bit My Cousin Vinny Vibes right you know
he's going to be practicing this in jail
he's getting a good night's sleep I mean
that's the first thing that came to my
mind no laughing matter but what a weird
development in this case if it ever ends
up going to trial